elle vient d'être élu président de
l'assemblée nationale yaël brawn pivert
recueilli 242 voix au second tour c'est
la première femme à occuper cette
fonction importante au sein du parlement
la députée blinoise succède à richard
ferrand mes chers collègues
qu'il est long et signent eux le chemin
de l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes le 21 octobre 1945 33 femmes
entrent pour la toute première fois dans
cet hémicycle
et encore 20 ans pour qu'elle accède à
une présidence de commission puis 20 ans
à nouveau pour qu'une classe leur soit
faite à la questure et presqu'autant
avant que ne soit créé la délégation aux
droits des femmes et à l'égalité des
chances nommé ministre d outre mer dans
le gouvernement d'elisabeth bornes le 20
mai dernier elle a démissionné dimanche
26 juin du fait de sa candidature au
perchoir le 19 juin dernier elle a été
réélu député de la 5e circonscription
des yvelines une victoire en demi-teinte
sans majorité absolue par le groupe
ensemble ça va être difficile parce que
notre notre assemblée et a été bâti pour
fonctionner selon une règle majoritaire
en appui du programme d'un gouvernement
nous ne sommes pas dans un régime
parlementaire et donc il va falloir
trouver des majorités aller chercher des
consensus c'est forcément plus compliqué
mais c'est ce que les français
souhaitent que nous fassions donc il
faut que nous nous soyons soyons
maintenant à leur écoute à 51 ans yale
brebis v aura la tâche de présider
l'assemblée nationale une institution
qu'elle connaît bien depuis 2010 est
elle a été présidente de la commission
des lois une activité parlementaire
reconnu notamment lors de la dernière
cérémonie du trombinoscope elle a été
désigné député de l'année moi je
n'abandonne jamais je ne renonce jamais
et je suis très positive très optimiste
et donc je me dis toujours que je vais y
arriver quelle que soit la difficulté
quelle que soit l'adversité et je crois
que finalement c'est dans la vie il faut
il faut avoir cette ténacité là et cet
espoir cette volonté farouche y arriver
c'est là que je retrouve yale que je
vais trouvant des poussées c'est cette
capacité à créer du lien et faire
apparaître l'humain yaël brawn pie v une
femme de loi avocate au barreau de paris
elle s'est aussi engagée au sein des
restos du coeur sur l'accès à la justice
membre du parti socialiste elle s'engage
en politique en 2017 au sein de la
république en marche un mouvement dans
lequel elle se reconnaît c'est une
vision pragmatique des questions des
problèmes quelque chose qui réunit les
gens quels que soient justement leurs
origines politiques leurs opinions avec
le souhait de poser les choses de
réfléchir d'échanger de débattre et
d'essayer de construire des solutions
pour l'avenir et trouver des solutions
pour l'avenir sera son défi depuis le
perchoir de l'assemblée nationale où
elle devra créer du lien consensuelle
entre les différents partis de
l'hémicycle